Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告知大家一件目前正在发生的好消息。如果你曾想过如何创造能够为你带来收益的收入，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向经常性收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Hi, welcome along to today's podcast episode, which is a little bit different than
这些原则同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一小时教练辅导的机会。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发一条简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。嗨，欢迎收看今天的播客节目，这期节目与以往有些不同。
usual. It is my first on tour. There might be a little bit of jiggly camera work here and there, and I'm sorry. Please do persevere with it. I will find somewhere to prop it up when I can, but you are coming on tour with me to Galway and we are going to go and do a keynote speech. And there's lots and lots of steps involved with getting me from my front door to the stage and then back again. So I hope you enjoyed today's episode and yeah, I hope it all works, but you'll be there with me every step of the way and we can do this together. All right. Take care. See you soon. I am just waiting for my Uber.
这是我的第一次“巡演”。这里可能会有些晃动的镜头，对此我深表歉意。请大家多多包涵。一有机会我就会找地方把镜头架起来，但这次你要和我一起去高尔夫（Galway）进行一次主旨演讲。从我离开前门到登上舞台，再到返回，中间有非常多的步骤。所以希望大家喜欢今天的节目，也希望一切都能顺利，但你将全程陪伴着我，我们可以一起做到这一点。好了。保重。回头见。我正在等我的优步（Uber）。
Okay. So I know the plan originally was to film all of this on my iPhone, but I realised that seeing as most of the listeners to this podcast episode do listen on MP3, that if I didn't do some sort of main feed with me talking you through the processes, that it might not make a whole heap of sense. But that said, this is going to be best viewed on YouTube. So even if you've downloaded this as an MP3 on Spotify or Apple, Amazon, you know, maybe come and take a little look over at YouTube. Dr. Marianne Trent. Whilst you're there, why not subscribe, like, fling a few comments around. So, yeah, I wanted to make this as
好了。我知道原本的计划是将这一切都在我的 iPhone 上拍摄，但我意识到，既然这个播客节目的绝大多数听众都是通过 MP3 收听的，如果我不做某种带大家了解整个过程的主音频流，可能会让人觉得有些摸不着头脑。话虽如此，这段视频在 YouTube 上观看效果最好。所以，即使你是在 Spotify、Apple 或 Amazon 上下载了 MP3，你也可以来 YouTube 上稍微看一看。Dr. Marianne Trent。在你浏览的同时，不妨订阅、点赞、留下几条评论。所以，是的，我想让这个过程对
useful a process and interesting a process as possible for those watching on YouTube and for those listening on your phones or however you do indeed listen to your MP3 content. Right, so let me give you a little bit of background into why I was going to Galway and how it came about. So in I think it was probably June or July, I was first contacted to ask if I might be available and up for coming to an in-person conference in Galway. I was contacted by a lovely, lovely person called Hannah Flynn. And she was so kind. She was organizing the conference for the Irish Psychological Society and she'd been just so accommodating and welcoming and friendly and when I met her in person she was equally as lovely. I wish we'd got a selfie Hannah that
在 YouTube 上观看的人以及在手机上收听（或无论你通过何种方式收听 MP3 内容）的人来说，尽可能地有用和有趣。好了，让我简单向大家介绍一下我去高尔夫的背景以及它是如何促成的。所以我想大概是在六月或七月，我第一次被联系，问我是否有空并愿意去高尔夫参加一个线下会议。联系我的是一个非常非常可爱的人，名叫汉娜·弗林（Hannah Flynn）。她太友善了。她在为爱尔兰心理学会（Irish Psychological Society）组织会议，一直非常体贴、热情和友好，当我见到她本人时，她同样非常可爱。我真希望我们能拍张自拍，汉娜，
would have been nice that would have been fun. So we finally got the venue sealed as being Galway University, which had been some of the hold up. That was finalised just towards the end of July. And then I went on holiday sort of immediately. And then it was kind of promotion central from the Irish Psychological Society. And then it happened in September. So that's a little bit of timeline and context into how this came about. And I was asked in my capacity as a qualified psychologist to do an hour's talk, not necessarily specifically from a clinical psychology discipline, because the conference happens every year, also, I learned on the day. And it's for people in the first 10 years of their graduation from a psychology degree.
那会很棒，也会很有趣。所以我们最终敲定场地为高尔夫大学（Galway University），这之前曾是耽搁的原因之一。这在七月底刚刚敲定。然后我几乎立刻就去度假了。接着就是爱尔兰心理学会的中央宣传期。然后它在九月举行了。这就是事情经过的时间线和背景。我被邀请以合格心理学家的身份做一个小时的演讲，不一定非要具体从临床心理学学科出发，因为据我在当天了解到，这个会议每年都会举办。它是为获得心理学学位后前十年的人士举办的。
And what we know about psychology degrees is that often, they will take people in very different directions, sometimes in the direction of becoming a qualified psychologist, and sometimes in, you know, very different directions that can be equally as fulfilling for people. So yeah, there's many, many steps involved in getting me from my home to Galway, and to the university and back. But I thought it was quite a fun little road trip idea for a podcast so I do hope you find this useful and I'll do my best to guide you through it. So with no further ado yeah let's get started let's get on the road shall we. So I decided I was going to get an Uber to the airport because the parking didn't seem to be worthwhile and I thought
我们对心理学学位的了解是，它们通常会将人们带向截然不同的方向，有时是成为合格心理学家的方向，有时则是带向（你知道的）对人们同样充实的截然不同的方向。所以，是的，从我的家到高尔夫，再到大学和返回，涉及非常非常多的步骤。但我认为这对于播客来说是一个非常有趣的小公路旅行想法，所以我真的希望你能觉得这很有用，我会尽力引导你完成它。废话不多说，让我们开始吧，上路吧。所以我决定叫一辆优步去机场，因为停车似乎不划算，而且我想
it would be a lot less faff to just be able to you know order and go so that's what I did but the thing I hadn't quite expected although I should have done because the same thing happened when I went to Birmingham with a friend for dinner one night is that it was a hot day and the driver clearly didn't want to switch the air con on and so instead had the windows open and my hair was just going wild which wasn't so bad when I was about to take a flight but when I was about to go out for dinner with a friend and I had preened and curled my hair it was less than ideal so yeah have a look at that for yourselves I hope you can hear me okay it's really noisy here um so the journey in the uber went really smoothly um and randomly um the taxi driver who's originally from Ghana had lived in Malwa for 17 years. I couldn't make that up, so he's giving me all of his top tips.
只需下单就走会省去很多麻烦，所以我就这么做了。但我没有完全预料到的是——尽管我本该想到的，因为我和朋友有一天晚上去伯明翰时也发生了同样的事情——那是热天，司机明显不想开空调，于是把车窗开着，我的头发简直乱飞。如果我正准备坐飞机倒也罢了，但如果我正准备和朋友出去吃晚餐，而且我之前还精心打理和卷过头发，这就远非理想了。所以，大家自己看吧。希望你们能听清我说话，这里真的很吵。嗯，优步的行程非常顺利。嗯，
We're doing some work here at Birmingham Airport, so it is quite noisy. So, yeah, I hope you can hear me okay. Annoyingly, Ryanair won't let me check in until 1.20, which is a bit annoying. Which now means I am in a cafe with some cake and a herbal tea and you know me I do love my herbal tea. I realised I think I said they won't let me check until 1.20 but I didn't say what time it is now so the time now is 5 to 12 so yeah I'm gonna walk around there again in just over an hour and just sit here with a magazine and pass the time. So I absolutely did sit there for a little while and then I thought you know what Ryanair,
巧合的是，这位原本来自加纳的出租车司机已经在马拉维（Malwa）住了17年。我绝对编不出这样的事，所以他正在给我他所有的绝招。我们在伯明翰机场这里做一些施工，所以真的很吵。所以，嗯，希望你们能听清我说话。讨厌的是瑞安航空（Ryanair）不让我办理登机手续，直到1.20，这有点烦人。这现在意味着我在一家咖啡馆里吃着蛋糕喝着花草茶，你们知道我有多爱我的花草茶。我意识到，我想我刚才说他们不让我办理登机手续直到1.20，但我没说现在几点。所以现在的时间是12点差5分。所以，嗯，我将在一个多小时后再走过去，然后就坐在这里拿本杂志消磨时间。所以我确实在那里坐了一会儿，然后我想，你知道吗，瑞安航空，
it is a self bag drop and so I'm gonna chance my arm again, I'm gonna meander on over there but the same lady saw me again and said oh dear um she's already told me not to come through and so then a few minutes later as I stood there waiting I saw her go off what looked like a lunch break so I joined the queue and the new person um on Ryanair didn't ask where I was going um just to check my passport and so then I went to the self bag drop, dropped my bag and went through to security so yeah always pushing the boundaries a little bit but you know I had places I wanted to be, I had my laptop with me and so I wanted to be you know a little bit further ahead not in that very noisy pre-security airport departures section so there I was found myself getting through security pretty effortlessly although I did forget to take my laptop out the bag and then I was free to explore the duty free. I managed not to buy anything but
这是一个自助行李托运处，所以我要再碰碰运气，我要晃晃悠悠地走过去。但同一个女士又看到了我，说“哦亲爱的，她之前已经告诉过我不要从这里进来了”。然后几分钟后，当我站在那里等待时，我看到她去吃午饭了，所以我排队了。瑞安航空的新员工没有问我要去哪里，只是检查了我的护照，然后我就去了自助行李托运处，托运了行李，通过了安检。所以，是的，总是有点在边缘试探，但你知道的，我有想去的地方，我随身带着笔记本电脑，所以我希望能（你知道的）再往前推进一点，而不是留在那个非常吵闹的安检前机场出发区。所以，我在那里发现自己毫不费力地通过了安检，虽然我确实忘了把笔记本电脑从包里拿出来，然后我就可以自由探索免税店了。我设法没买任何东西，但是
yeah it's always something about that environment of walking through, smelling all the perfume, seeing all the Toblerone bars that you definitely don't need. I do like travelling and yeah I found travelling independently to be pretty good too. I will admit that I wasn't really looking forward to the time in the airport lounge waiting for my flight. That is because I'd taken a flight from Birmingham Airport over the summer and our flight had then been delayed for three hours. And what I observed was that if you hadn't got there early enough there was nowhere to sit and it wasn't particularly enjoyable now of course I did have young children with me for that trip which always adds an element of pressure and for this one I was traveling solo but I decided if I was going to be delayed I would rather be delayed where I could work from my laptop and where I had
是的，走过那种环境、闻着所有的香水味、看到所有你绝对不需要的三角巧克力（Toblerone）的体验总是有些特别。我确实喜欢旅行，是的，我也发现独立旅行挺不错的。我承认，我其实并不期待在机场贵宾室等待航班的那段时光。那是因为我今年夏天从伯明翰机场乘过一次航班，当时我们的航班延误了三个小时。我观察到的是，如果你没有足够早地到达，就没有地方坐，而且也不是特别愉快。当然，那次旅行我带着幼童，这总是会增加压力，而这次我是独自出行。但我决定，如果航班要延误，我宁愿在可以从笔记本电脑上工作的地方、在有
power in case I needed to charge my phone and also where I had food so I did treat myself to an airport lounge it cost me 38 pounds and had I been able to spend three hours in there that would have been marvellous but I was able to get myself some food which was a little bit uninspiring I had a little glass of wine and I had a little clotted cream scone then I was able to sit and do some work I planned some social media wine and I had a little clotted cream scone. Then I was able to sit and do some work. I planned some social media content and I did some email scheduling ahead for my membership and so it felt like a good use of time and I was also able to keep an eye on the departures board. Would I recommend using a lounge and would I use one in future? So it was my first time in a lounge and would I use one in future so it was my first time in a lounge and I would say if I was
电源（以防我需要给手机充电）以及有食物的地方延误。所以我确实犒劳了自己一次，去了一趟机场贵宾室，花了我38英镑。如果我能在里面待上三个小时，那就太美妙了。但我确实给自己弄了点吃的，虽然有点索然无味，我喝了一小杯葡萄酒，吃了一个凝脂奶油司康饼。然后我坐下来工作了一会儿。我规划了一些社交媒体内容，并为我的会员提前安排了电子邮件调度，所以感觉时间没有白费，我也能随时关注出发显示屏。我会推荐使用贵宾室吗？以后我还会使用吗？这是我第一次去贵宾室，至于以后还会不会去，我想说如果我
traveling again by myself I would definitely do that again because it just it was so quiet and so peaceful and it meant I had a guaranteed place to sit where there wasn't any chaos going on and yeah whilst it would have been cheaper to go to Wetherspoons I feel like it would have been more stressful and in terms of doing myself a kindness ahead of my trip and my presentation the next day I really felt that would be yeah the most compassionate thing I could do for myself because I was worried about all of these steps you know there were a lot of steps from taking me to my front door and then back the other side and so it just felt like a little bit of a reward to kind of yeah give me a little pat on the back and say it's all right
再次独自旅行，我绝对会再去一次，因为那里实在太安静、太祥和了，这意味着我有一个保证有座位的地方，周围没有任何混乱。是的，虽然去韦瑟斯poons（Wetherspoons）会更便宜，但我觉得那样压力会更大。为了在旅程和第二天演讲前对自己好一点，我真的觉得这将是对自己最体贴的做法，因为我担心所有这些步骤——你知道的，从带我离开前门到另一侧的返回，中间有太多的步骤。所以这感觉就像是一个小小的奖励，（你知道的）拍拍自己的肩膀说：“没关系，
Marianne it's okay this is this is kind of one step further in your journey so yeah that is I would I would do it on a case-by-case basis i probably wouldn't pay for for my children to join me um but i would definitely go if i was going by myself again right i booked the airport and it said it was closest to where ryan i buy an air fly um or by gate one and now my flight's been announced as gate 57 so I have a bit of a dash to get there okay I'm in the queue to board I'll admit I'm a little bit hot and bothered I have to say that it all went pretty smoothly for Ryanair from the point that I dropped my bag. Everything happened as it needed to happen. I was able to board the plane, find my seat,
玛丽安，没关系的，这是你旅程中又向前迈进了一步。”所以，是的，我会根据具体情况来决定，我可能不会为我的孩子们支付加入的费用，但如果我自己再去，我绝对会去。好了，我预订了机场，上面说它离瑞安航空飞机的起飞地点最近，或者在1号登机口附近，现在我的航班广播通知在57号登机口，所以我得冲过去。好了，我在登机队伍里了。我承认我有点热和烦躁。我必须说，从我托运行李的那一刻起，瑞安航空的一切都相当顺利。一切都按需要的那样发生了。我顺利登机，找到座位，
settle down. It was very hot on board initially because it was a super warm weekend. If you're listening to this in the UK, it was the weekend in September where the temperatures were above 30 degrees and it was so warm everyone was completely sweltering. The flight itself was good it was it was nice to be able to spend a little bit of time doing a little bit of puzzling. I'm a big fan of like that's life and take a break puzzles and so I did a little bit of that and read a bit of my book. I looked out the window it was really nice to kind of watch the scenery go by, watch the clouds go by and then to see as Ireland appeared and got gradually greener and greener so it was a very different experience than traveling with children so I did rather enjoy that yeah and then we got off the plane and it was a really tiny airport
安顿下来。机舱里最初非常热，因为这是一个超级温暖的周末。如果你在英国听到这个，这就是九月那个气温超过30度的周末，天气太热了，每个人都在大汗淋漓。飞行本身很不错，能够花一点时间玩玩拼图感觉很好。我是那种喜欢《生活》（That's Life）和《休息》（Take a Break）拼图的超级粉丝，所以我做了一点，读了一会儿书。我看着窗外，看着风景掠过、云朵掠过，然后看到爱尔兰出现并变得越来越绿，这真的是一种与带着孩子旅行截然不同的体验，所以我真的很享受。然后我们下了飞机，这是一个非常小的机场
so I'd flown into Knock airport and it was just really small and really cute and yeah it all went seamlessly once I got in the airport there was like this lovely sunny photo wall that said welcome to knock and so I thought it's the perfect place for a selfie it would be rude not to right here I am at knock airport I've just picked up the keys for my car hire hire car hire car uh let's go and see if I can find it then was trying to find which one the car rental desk was so I've not hired a car since I was in New Zealand in 2003 so it was a little bit rusty um about how to do that um but yeah it went it went well it went smoothly it's a little bit of a queue because by the time I found the right desk everybody else had already beaten me to it.
——我飞到了诺克机场（Knock airport），它真的很小、很可爱，一切都很顺利。我一进机场，就看到一面阳光灿烂的合影墙，上面写着“欢迎来到诺克”，所以我想这绝对是自拍的完美地方，不做点什么就太失礼了对吧？我在这里，在诺克机场。我刚拿到租车的钥匙，租的车，租的车……嗯，去看看能不能找到它。然后我一直在努力寻找租车柜台在哪里。自从2003年在新西兰以来，我就再也没租过车，所以对于怎么做有点生疏了。不过，进展顺利。排了一小会儿队，因为当我找到正确的柜台时，其他所有人都已经抢在我前面了。
But yeah, it was good. And I then got to learn which car I was having. Well, I've managed to find my car. It is a Dacia Duster. I've never driven one of those before. Have been in one. Almost bought one when I was pregnant with my oldest child. But my husband test drove it.
不过，挺好的。然后我得知了我将开什么车。好吧，我成功找到了我的车。这是一辆达契亚达斯特（Dacia Duster）。我以前从没开过这种车。坐过一次。在我怀着大宝时差点买了一辆。但我丈夫试驾了它，
Said it was awful. So let's see how it goes that's it luggage stowed managed to somehow work out how to open the boot now I've got to drive and find myself on the way to the Airbnb in Galway there was this error that seemed to be on the dashboard for the car for the whole trip I just don't think I noticed it to begin with and it said inflate tyres and in it and I think that meant there was some sort of sensor on the car which had sort of inflated the tyres but letting you know that they needed some attention so I don't know it seemed to be fine. The only thing I struggled with was I've got an automatic handbrake and I did
说它太糟糕了。所以让我们看看它表现如何吧。好了，行李放好了，不知怎么弄明白了怎么打开后备箱。现在我得开车去找去高尔夫的 Airbnb 民宿了。一路上，车子的仪表盘上似乎一直有个错误提示，整个行程中都有，我一开始只是没注意到，上面写着“给轮胎充气”。我想这意味着车上某种传感器检测到了轮胎情况，但提醒你需要注意轮胎，所以不知道，它看起来似乎没问题。我唯一的挣扎是这辆车有自动手刹，而我
keep forgetting to take it off but all went well and then as I was driving oh I was so delighted when I turned on the radio are you even in Ireland if when you get there on the radio they're not playing Westlife on the radio they're not playing west life so it was a little over an hour and a half driving through um yeah pretty main roads i would say violent mainly motorways um but yeah they were fairly well behaved considering it was um rush hour it was around 5 p.m by the time i landed so yeah it was it was pretty good and um and as i was driving along I was listening to the iRadio and I said what is this? They kept referring to the ploughing championships and I'd never heard of that before and they were giving away tickets to the ploughing championships and I couldn't quite work out why the people that won them sounded so excited. That's something I asked the guide,
一直忘记把它松开。不过一切都很顺利。然后当我开车时，哦，当我打开收音机时我太高兴了——你去爱尔兰如果收音机里不放西城男孩（Westlife），你算什么到了爱尔兰？所以他们播放了西城男孩。开车一个多小时，穿过主要的道路，我想主要是高速公路。但考虑到当时是交通高峰期，大概在我落地时是下午5点，它们开得还算不错。所以，是的，相当不错。而且当我开车时，我在听爱尔兰电台（iRadio），我说：“这是什么？”他们一直提到“犁地锦标赛”（ploughing championships），我以前从没听说过这个，他们还在送犁地锦标赛的门票，我有点想不通为什么赢得门票的人听起来那么兴奋。这是我问导游的一个问题——
who you'll hear a little bit more about later in the video, about what it was. Why were people so excited about this ploughing championship? And I was informed that it's a really big deal. And people, it's like a festival. People, there'll be bands there, there'll be activities, there'll be things to buy and things to do. It sounds a bit like Glastonbury and apparently people don't always watch the ploughing so it started as the ploughing and yeah it's it's it's apparently really really fun so I was almost sad that I wasn't going to be there for a ploughing weekend which I think was the weekend after I was there but I learned a little bit there about Irish culture and yeah I feel a little bit less naive in terms of at least where ploughing championships come in
你会在视频后面听到更多关于她的介绍——问那是什么。为什么人们对这个犁地锦标赛这么兴奋？我被告知这是一件大事。人们，这就像一个节日。人们会在那里有乐队、有活动、有可以买的东西和可以做的事情。这听起来有点像格拉斯顿伯里音乐节（Glastonbury），而且显然人们并不总是看犁地，所以它最初是作为犁地开始的，是的，显然它真的非常非常有趣。所以我甚至有点难过我不能在那里参加犁地周末（我想那是我离开后的那个周末）。但我学到了一些关于爱尔兰文化的知识，是的，在至少知道犁地锦标赛是什么方面，我觉得自己没那么天真了。
so I managed to find myself there and was delighted to see a lovely lovely cat who lived at the B&B welcoming me in. You are so cute. Now I had booked on Airbnb and it looked all right you know the downstairs areas look wonderful. I knew I was going to be having my own bathroom but it wasn't en suite and it looked okay but what I wasn't prepared for was that it just blew me away. The lady who was hosting me was wonderfully warm, welcoming, so friendly, so chatty, such an interesting, interesting life that she'd had. And her home was immaculate. She could have been an interior designer and it was just all completely lovely. So once I was settled
所以我设法找到了那个地方，很高兴看到住在 B&B 的一只非常可爱的小猫欢迎我进来。你太可爱了。现在我是在 Airbnb 上预订的，它看起来还不错，楼下的区域看起来棒极了。我知道我会有自己的浴室，但它不是套内卫浴，看起来还可以。但我没有准备好的是，它直接把我惊艳到了。接待我的女主人热情得不得了，非常受欢迎，非常友好，非常健谈，有着一段非常非常有趣的人生。而且她的家一尘不染。她完全可以去当室内设计师，一切都绝对完美。所以一旦我安顿
in I took a stroll into the local area of where I was staying and went and got myself some dinner and on the way I saw a beautifully decorated apothecary clinic and I just thought it was a really lovely looking building. It would have made a really nice therapeutic space if you were going to be setting up a private practice as well. I found myself in the most beautiful street. I wish I'd taken a photo of it. I walked down it the next day in the daylight hours and it looked completely different because the street was open it had beautiful beautiful lights all above it and because it was a beautiful warm summer's evening everybody was outside there was tables in the road and it just looked like the buzziest most fun
下来，我就在当地我住的街区散了散步，去吃晚饭。在路上，我看到了一家装饰精美的药房诊所，我只是觉得它是一个看起来非常可爱的建筑。如果你要建立一个私人诊所，它也会成为一个非常好的治疗空间。我发现自己身处最美丽的街道。我真希望我拍了张照片。第二天白天我走过这条街时，它看起来完全不同，因为街道是开阔的，上方全都是美丽夺目的灯光。因为这是一个美丽的温暖夏夜，每个人都在外面，马路上摆着桌子，它看起来像是最具活力、最有趣的
street but everywhere was kind of pricey for me just eating dinner by myself when I just wanted to eat and then a little bit further along still under the beautiful string light I found a cafe called the secret garden I went in there and I had a lovely curry and they treated me really nicely and then I treated myself to a little pudding as well I think it was a homemade rhubarb crumble it was good and the next morning my lovely Airbnb hostess did me proud with a really beautiful breakfast so I'd taken my running gear with me and I was planning on going for a run but when I was chatting to her the day before she said that she just really loves the company of people and chatting and learning about their stories so I
街道，但对于我这个只想吃点东西的独自用餐者来说，到处都有点贵。然后又往前走了一点，仍然在美丽的串灯下，我找到了一家名为“秘密花园”（The Secret Garden）的咖啡馆。我进去了，吃了一份美味的咖喱，他们对我也非常好。然后我还犒劳了自己一份小甜点，我想那是自制的果酱大黄酥（rhubarb crumble），味道很好。第二天早上，我亲爱的 Airbnb 女主人用一顿非常丰美的早餐招待了我。我带了跑步装备，本来打算去跑步的，但前一天和她聊天时，她说她真的很喜欢陪伴人们、聊天以及了解他们的故事，所以我
decided that it would be really better for me and better for her if I was to sit down and have breakfast and continue to chat with her rather than the benefit I would get from going for a run by myself so that is what I do. Okay so I am ready I have breakfasted I have got myself into my outfit I've eaten my breakfast in a tea towel so that it doesn't mess up my outfit I had a slight difficulty with the necklace I want to wear so it's quite special to me because it was given to me by my first supervisor when I was a trainee and she's no longer with us so I wanted to wear it to bring something of her to the event but unfortunately when I got it out of the pouch I'd kept it in it somehow broke in itself into several different pieces so I've sort of had to hodgepodge it together to put that bit behind here but it is supposed to so I've sort of had to hodgepodge it together to put
决定，如果我坐下来吃早餐并继续和她聊天，对我对她都会更好，而不是我自己去跑步能得到的好处，所以我就这么做了。好了，我已经准备好了，我吃过早餐了，换好了衣服。我用茶巾包着吃早餐，这样就不会弄脏我的衣服。我对我想要戴的项链遇到了一点小困难，它对我很特别，因为它是我的第一位主管在我还是实习生时送给我的，而她已经不在了，所以我想戴着它把她的一部分带到活动中去。但不幸的是，当我把它从装它的袋子里拿出来时，它不知怎么自己断成了好几截，所以我不得不把它七拼八凑地把那部分别在后面，但它本应该是
that bit behind here but it is supposed to come down to sort of stomach level so I'll have to do some sort of more permanent fix when I go home but for today that's it I've just got a jacket I'm gonna wear I've got to change my shoes because they're quite high I'm not gonna manage to wear those um all day um so I'll change those just before I go to the venue. Right, I'll see you there. Take care. Okay, so I'm hoping that I am here at the university. Oh, my windscreen wipers seem to be on. I don't know how to turn them off because the key is not in the ignition.
垂到胃部水平的，所以我回家后必须做一些更永久的修复。但对于今天来说就是这样，我只有一件要穿的外套。我得换鞋，因为它们太高了，我没法整天穿着它们，所以我会在去会场前换掉它们。好了，回头见。保重。好了，我希望我已经到了大学。哦，我的雨刷器好像开着。我不知道怎么关掉它，因为钥匙不在点火开关里。
I almost hit myself in the face with the boot as it came up. I managed to avert that. It's quite a vicious little boot, this Dacia Duster. I wasn't expecting that. I hope I'm quite near the university building where I'm going to be going in. Yeah, don't know if I'm parked in the right place. Sort of hope that I am. Parking, I won't lie makes me a
我差点被弹起的后备箱砸到脸。我设法避开了。这个达契亚达斯特的后备箱还真是个有点凶猛的小家伙。我没想到。我希望我离我要进去的大学建筑很近。是的，不知道我有没有停在对的地方。我有点希望我停对了。说实话，停车让我
bit anxious no one likes the idea of being clamped but it did say like white line spaces are not enforceable at weekends but none of the signs seem to say that so hopefully be okay I'm only here for sort of about two hours by the time it's all done and dusted so here we go um don't know how much I'll be able to talk to you in the event if at all um but I might see you well I will see you on the other side so me and my broken necklace my laptop I've got to change my shoes because I'm not going to manage to walk around in the very high heels that I'm wearing um even for two whole hours uh my lovely Airbnb host has given me a little bag to put my trainers in when I'm not wearing them um she's so lovely so I'll see you soon so I was in the event I was in the queue with the delegates waiting to go in and I was like oh I'm a little bit nervous and then yeah I went to the
有点焦虑，没有人喜欢车轮被锁的想法，但上面确实写着白线车位周末不强制执行，不过所有的标志似乎都没有这么说，所以希望没问题。等一切结束，我在这里大约也就待两个小时。所以，这里我们去……不知道在活动中我能对你说多少话（如果有的话），但我可能会见到你——嗯，我会在另一边见到你。所以，我和我断了的项链、我的笔记本电脑……我得换鞋，因为我没法穿着我脚上这双非常高的鞋子四处走动，哪怕只是整整两个小时。我亲爱的 Airbnb 主人给了我一个小包，让我在不穿运动鞋时把它们放进去，她太友善了。所以我们回见。我在活动中，我和代表们一起在队伍里等待入场，当时我想：“哦，我有点紧张。”然后，是的，我走到
front of the queue and I said oh I'm Marianne I'm here to do here to do the keynote speech and everyone sort of turned around and looked at me and yeah then I was chatting to Hannah it was lovely to meet Hannah in person and then I was chatting to Hannah. It was lovely to meet Hannah in person. And then I was chatting to some delegates. I was having a look at the poster conference and I went and changed my shoes. And then I decided I was going to go into the auditorium early and talk to some of the people that were there. I was chatting to three people at various different stages of their journey and it was really refreshing actually because I'd sort of written the speech with aspiring psychologists in mind being at different stages of their career and yet someone was an assistant psychologist someone's about to start a master's you know on the Monday after the event and so yeah it felt like I pitched it appropriately and it was just really nice to speak with them and I as I was chatting um to one of them well another one turned around and went oh I believe you might be our keynote and I was like yeah I am ah it felt a bit strange but
队伍最前面说：“哦，我是玛丽安，我是来做主旨演讲的。”每个人都转过身看着我，然后我和汉娜聊天，很高兴能见到汉娜本人。然后我和一些代表聊天。我看了一下海报会议，然后去换了鞋。接着我决定提前走进礼堂，和里面的一些人交谈。我和处于旅程不同阶段的三个人聊了天，这其实真的很refreshing（提神/耳目一新），因为我写演讲时本来是把有志成为心理学家的人作为不同职业阶段的受众，而结果有人是助理心理学家，有人在活动后的周一就要开始读硕士。所以，是的，我觉得我定位得很合适，能和他们交谈真的很棒。当我正和其中一个人聊天时，另一个人转过身说：“哦，我相信你可能是我们的主旨发言人。”我说：“是的，我是。”啊，感觉有点奇怪，但
yeah nice it nice and you know the speech went well well and people sort of ran out after me to go and speak to me so it felt like a really nice thing to have done and yeah I talked through my outfit on stage and why it was significant so the skirt I was wearing I bought when I learned that I was going to be an assistant psychologist at St Andrews Healthcare because I believed I needed assistant psychologist outfits. The je Healthcare because I believed I needed assistant psychologist outfits. The jewellery I was wearing was something I'd had made when I was travelling in Morocco and the necklace as I've explained to you was very significant because of who gave it to me and it just felt really important that I'd be able to bring the different stages of myself
是的，挺好的，而且（你知道的）演讲进展顺利，人们在演讲结束后追着我出来和我说话，所以感觉这是一件非常棒的事情。是的，我在舞台上讲了我的服装以及它为什么重要。我穿的这条裙子是我得知自己将成为圣安德鲁斯医疗保健公司（St Andrews Healthcare）的助理心理学家时买的，因为我相信我需要助理心理学家的服装。我戴的首饰是我在摩洛哥旅行时定制的，正如我向你解释的那样，那条项链非常重要，因为它是谁送给我的。能够将我人生中的不同阶段带到舞台上，并在舞台上代表它们，这让我觉得非常重要。所以这感觉真的很棒。这意味着我不需要出去购物买新东西，这对钱包来说也更好。好吧，就是这样。我都完成了。高尔夫正用一点小雨款待我们，但一切顺利。所以我会在车里跟你说话。
and have them be represented on stage with me. So that felt really lovely. And it meant that I didn't need to go out shopping and buy something new, which was also better for the purse strings too. Well, that's it. I'm all done. Galway's treating us to a little bit of rain, but it went well. So I'll speak to you from the car.
我又来了，回到了我的小车办公室。所以我想一切顺利。人们在离开的路上停下来告诉我他们有多么享受。几个人对我说的一些话笑了，这很好。不是从头笑到尾，那样就怪了。但是，是的，反响很热烈。我设法将七种不同的执业心理学家学科编织到我的演讲中，以一种希望引人入胜且合乎逻辑的方式。因为会议是为毕业后头十年的人士举办的，这听起来像是一个非常非常好的组织，也是一种非常支持性的方式，可以帮助推动人们进入职业生涯的下一个阶段，无论他们在哪里都给予他们支持和启发。所以，是的，非常荣幸能去那里，看到可爱的大学，再次回到演讲厅。
Here I am again, back in my little car office. So I think it went well. People sort of stopped me on the way out saying how much they'd enjoyed it. A few people laughed at some of the stuff I said, which is good. Not all the way through, that would be weird. But yeah, the reception was warm. I managed to weave in seven different practitioner, psychologists, disciplines into my speech in a way that hopefully was engaging and made sense. Because the conference is for people in the first 10 years post-graduation, which sounds like a really, really nice organisation and a really supportive way of helping advance people to the next stages of their career and supporting and inspiring them wherever they are. So, yeah, it was absolute pleasure to be there, to see the lovely uni, to be back in, you know, lecture theatre as well.
所以如果你在舞台上看我，希望它对你有所帮助。至于我的感觉，我想我有点紧张关于停车的事（我之前提到过），并且确保我能在正确的时间、正确的建筑里，因为我甚至从来没去过高尔夫，更不用说高尔夫大学了，更不用说我要去的特定建筑了。所以（你知道的）让自己对没做过的事情感到有些犹豫是可以的，但显然要给自己充足的时间，以确保你能按正确的顺序通过考验，并仍然给自己留出时间来放松，希望不那么出汗，因为天气一直很暖和。是的，现在雨下得有点大了，所以我没有带伞。我预订了今天晚上的高尔夫步行游览，
So if you watched me on stage hope it was useful um and in terms of how I felt um so I think I was a bit nervous about the parking which I mentioned earlier um and just making sure I was going to be there in the right time in the right building because I'd never even been to Galway before let alone sort of Galway Uni let alone the specific building that I was going to be in so you know it's always okay to let yourself be a bit hesitant about the things you've not done before but obviously give yourself plenty of time to make sure you can jump through the hoops in the right order and still give yourself time to to decompress and hopefully be a bit less sweaty because it has been very warm um yeah it is raining a bit now so um i didn't bring an umbrella so i've got a walking tour of galway booked in
希望到那时毛毛雨已经停了。在此之前，我还得去吃个午餐，所以我们很快就会再聊。我回到停车位了，我要去换身衣服，然后前往高尔夫市中心吃午餐。哦，我本想也告诉你关于我的租车的事，它有一个我显然不习惯的手刹，因为我一直忘记松开手刹。我家里车的自动手刹习惯了，到目前为止还没有人按喇叭，尽管我起步离开红绿灯时并不那么快，因为我拉着手刹。所以，是的，非常好，显然爱尔兰的司机比我习惯的要悠闲一些，这真的
later today and hopefully drizzled out by then and before then I've got to get a spot of lunch as well so I'll catch up with you very soon I am back in my parking space I'm gonna go and get changed and then I'm gonna head out into Galway and get some lunch oh I thought I'd tell you about my hire car as well so it's got like a manual handbrake that i'm clearly not used to um because i keep forgetting to take my handbrake off my handbrake on my car at home is automatic and so far nobody has honked me despite me not being that speedy getting away from the lights because i have my handbrake on so yes it's very nice clearly the drivers in Ireland are a little bit more laid back than I'm used to which is really
非常非常棒。在那之后，我进去换了衣服，收拾妥当，然后喝了杯茶，吃了一块蛋糕，和我的 Airbnb 女主人进行了很多很多美妙的交谈，简直太棒了。然后在那之后，我在美丽的高尔夫散步，我拍了一些前一天晚上那条美丽街道的视频，但它看起来太不一样了，因为道路是开着的，有交通（你知道的）上下行驶，而且还在下雨，所以这几乎让我有点难过，我无法拥有前一天晚上的那种氛围——当时有美妙的音乐播放，人们只是出来过着他们最好的生活，在街上的场馆里喝着饮料聊天，有着如此热烈、温馨的氛围。是的，它在白天看起来太不一样了。然后当我走进高尔夫时，
really nice so following that I went in and I got myself changed and sorted and then I had a cup of tea and a slice of cake and lots and lots of lovely chat with my lovely Airbnb host which was just marvellous and then following that I took a stroll into beautiful Galway and I took some video of the lovely street I'd been in the evening before but it looked so different because of course the road was open there was traffic you know driving up and down it and it was raining and so it almost made me a bit sad but I wasn't able to have the opportunity from the night before when there was lovely music playing and people were just out living their best lives having drinks in the venues in the street and chatting and there was just so much of a warm inviting atmosphere and yeah it just looked so different in the daytime and then as I was walking into Galway
我看到一块黑板招牌，上面写着那天下午晚些时候将有一场传统音乐会（traditional session），我心想：“哦，好吧，如果正好那时我还在镇上的话，我要进去，我要喝上一杯葡萄酒，享受聆听传统正宗的爱尔兰音乐会。”我喜欢靠近水的地方，当我走进高尔夫市中心时，看到河水真的很棒。我想那是科里布河（River Corrib），走在人们挂同心锁的桥上。感觉这是一个非常平静、安全的城市。这座城市松了一口气，因为前几天天气一直很暖和，所以穿一件轻便的牛仔夹克绝对很舒服，每个人都对天气不像前几天那么热感到高兴。所以对我来说，这座城市感觉有点像布赖顿（Brighton），但更安全，音乐更多——布赖顿也经常有音乐播放，但它就是——嗯，感觉非常爱尔兰，真的很棒，我真的很享受沉浸在其中的一切。我四处拍摄可能看起来有点奇怪，但真的很棒。所以我打算安静一分钟，让你听听那些音乐，看看一些景点，这正是去 YouTube 观看并在这里观看真正有价值的地方，这样你就可以……带有红门的特色建筑出现在埃德·希兰（Ed Sheeran）的《高尔夫女孩》（Galway Girl）的其中一个音乐录影带中，那正是我最终用餐的餐厅，它叫 Ard Beer，真的
I saw a blackboard sign that said there was a traditional session happening later that afternoon and I thought to myself oh well if it if it so happens I'm still in town by that time then I'm gonna I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna have a glass of wine and I'm gonna enjoy listening to a traditional authentic Irish session. I love being by water and as I was walking into Galway city centre it was really nice to see the river. I think it's the River Corrib and walking along the bridge where people have done love locks. It just felt like a wonderfully calm, safe city to be in. And the city was breathing a sigh of relief because it had been warm for the days preceding that and so it was definitely comfortable to wear a light denim jacket and everybody was kind of pleased it wasn't quite
非常非常时髦。我没有意识到的是它有多受欢迎，所以我最后排起了长队，因为我真的找不到我想吃的地方，外面的午餐菜单看起来棒极了。事实证明，当我进去时，他们给了我早午餐菜单。我不知道我是否去得太早了，赶不上午餐菜单，但当我到达时大约是12点，我到达时是12点30分，正是午餐时间，但工作人员对我很友好，我点了一份非常美味的水波蛋和火腿肘子早午餐，配上一杯康普茶（kombucha）。真的非常非常不错。然后我有一些空闲时间去探索高尔夫，然后去集合参加我的步行游览。所以，是的，查看高尔夫女孩雕像，发现在爱尔兰彩票和一些爱尔兰纪念品前拍一张小自拍。
so hot as it had been in the days before. So for me the city felt a little bit like Brighton but safer and with more sort of music playing which there is often music playing in Brighton but it just felt well it felt very Irish and it was really really lovely and I just really enjoyed soaking it all up I probably looked a little bit weird going around filming but it was just really nice so I'm going to shush for a minute and let you listen to some of that music and see some of the sites and this is where it really does pay to to come over to YouTube and watch it here so that you can just with the red door features in one of the videos for Ed Sheeran's songs for Galway Girl and that is the restaurant that I ended up eating in it's called Ard Beer and it's just really
我正要去参加步行游览。我在高尔夫博物馆旁边的西班牙拱门（Spanish Arch）集合。天还在下一点小雨。我穿着大衣，我看到英国的每个人目前都在融化。所以我很享受穿大衣。回头见。我预订了一次 Airbnb 体验，叫做“高尔夫传奇步行游览”（Galway's legendary walking tour），由一个叫尼尔（Neil）的小伙子带队。非常实惠，只要13英镑，历时一个半小时。我真的很希望我也能预订一个紧随其后开始的美食之旅，但当我发邮件询问开始和结束日期时，她已经卖出了最后一个名额，所以也许下次我访问高尔夫时能做到这一点。但这次游览真的很棒，
really funky and what I hadn't realized was how popular it is so I ended up standing in a queue because I couldn't really find anywhere that I wanted to eat and the lunch menu on the outside looked fabulous and as it turned out when I got in there they gave me the brunch menu I don't know if I was perhaps too early for the lunch menu but I think it was about 12 o'clock by the time I got there it was 12 30 by the time I got there which is lunchtime but the staff were really friendly to me and I ordered myself a really tasty poached egg and ham hock brunch with a kombucha. And it was really, really nice. And then I had some free time to explore Galway before meeting up with my walking tour. So, yeah, checking out the Galway girl statue, finding myself taking a little selfie in front of the Irish lottery and some Irish souvenirs.
非常私密，非常独特，因为我们只有三个人，当时爱尔兰正在打橄榄球赛，所以我想大多数人可能都在室内躲着毛毛雨在酒吧里看比赛。但了解更多关于这座城市的历史、理解绿色的邮箱为什么是绿色、为什么对于我们这些在英国长大的人来说看起来那么熟悉、了解这座城市的历史以及以前住在那里的人，真的很不错。我也真的很喜欢高尔夫的所有街头艺术，并且能够（你知道的）看到高尔夫的人们。有一个非常著名的角落，据说埃德·希兰过去常在那里卖艺，因为我想他的祖父母过去住在高尔夫，所以他在那里花了很多时间。
So I'm just about to go on my walking tour. I am at the Spanish Arch meeting by the museum in Galway. It's sort of raining a little bit still. I'm wearing a coat and I can see everyone in England currently is melting. So I'm quite enjoying wearing my coat I'll see you soon I had booked myself onto an Airbnb experience it was called Galway's legendary walking tour and it was by a chap called Neil really affordable it was only 13 pounds and it was an hour and a half what I was really hoping was that I could also book on to a food tour which was starting just after that but by the time I had emailed her to ask about start and finish dates she'd sold her last place so maybe next time I visit Galway I'll be able to do that but the tour was really lovely it was
所以我马上就要去参加徒步导览了。我现在在戈尔韦的博物馆旁边的西班牙拱门集合。天还在下着毛毛雨。我穿着外套，我看到现在英格兰每个人都热得快化了。所以我挺享受穿外套的，一会儿见。我预订了一个爱彼迎体验，叫做“戈尔韦传奇徒步导览”，带队的是一个叫尼尔的小伙子，非常划算，只要13英镑，时长一个半小时。我本来真的很希望能再预订一个美食团，那个团刚好在那之后不久开始，但等我发邮件询问开始和结束时间时，她已经把最后一个名额卖掉了，所以也许下次我访问戈尔韦的时候就能去参加了。不过这个导览真的很好，它
quite intimate it was quite unique because there was only three of us on there because Ireland were playing in the rugby so I think most people were probably inside avoiding the drizzle in the pub watching that but it was really nice to learn some more about the city to understand why the green post boxes are green and why they look so familiar to those of us that have grown up in the UK, to learn about the history of the city and those who've lived there before. I also really liked all of the street art in Galway as well and just being able to yeah to see the people of Galway and there's a very famous corner where apparently Ed Sheeran used to busk because I think his grandparents used to live in Galway so he spent a lot of time there
非常私密，非常独特，因为我们团只有三个人，当时爱尔兰队正在打橄榄球比赛，所以我想大多数人可能都在室内躲着毛毛雨，在酒吧里看比赛呢。不过，了解更多关于这座城市的知识真的很棒，明白了为什么绿色的邮筒是绿色的，为什么对我们这些在英国长大的人来说它们看起来那么熟悉，也了解了这座城市的历史以及以前生活在那里的人们。我也非常喜欢戈尔韦的所有街头艺术，能够亲眼看到戈尔韦的人民，还有一个非常著名的拐角，据说埃德·希兰过去经常在那里卖艺，因为我想他的祖父母以前住在戈尔韦，所以他在那里度过了很多时间。
and so it just yeah it's just lovely to watch the city to experience it and yeah just to enjoy it's free time it was great to be able to see the way that they had intertwined the old city. So the old city walls that now sit within one of the shopping centres there as well. And then before too long, it was time to say goodbye to Neil and to the lovely married couple who were visiting from America. Oh, let me say goodbye to you from that walking tour but I'll be back along in a moment. So in Ireland apparently you don't say goodbye you say safe home which was really nice to be able to capture on camera as well. I didn't get any photos of them when we were on the tour so it's nice to be able to say that and I did check with them that they
所以，看着这座城市，体验它，享受它的闲暇时光，真的是一件很美妙的事。很高兴能看到他们是如何将古城融为一体的。古城墙现在甚至也坐落在一个购物中心里面。不久之后，就到了该跟尼尔还有那对从美国来旅游的恩爱夫妻说再见的时候了。哦，请容许我先向你们在那个徒步导览中告别，我一会儿就回来。在爱尔兰，显然你不能说“再见”，而是说“一路平安”，能把这个情景用镜头记录下来真的很好。我们在导览时我没有给他们拍照片，所以能说出这番话真好，而且我也跟他们确认过他们
were happy for me to include them within this vlog and they were and in fact there will be details of Neil's legendary walking tour in the show notes if you do want to book that for your next trip to Galway and then a little bit of free time to be able to primarily buy my children gifts which was which was the agreement they had struck for me to be able to go off because they were like we'll miss you I was like I'll buy you presents they're like okay yay and so yeah I stumbled across a lovely vending machine selling sweets with the plan being that I would give a packet to each of my children but I also sort of gave them to the family as well and me and my husband devoured them I'm not sure the kids got much out of them at all but they were so delicious so if you see any hay candy vending machines or
乐意让我把他们剪进这个视频里，他们确实同意了。事实上，尼尔传奇般的徒步导览的详细信息会放在节目介绍里，如果你想为下次的高尔เว之行预订的话。接下来是一点自由活动时间，主要是给我的孩子们买礼物，这是他们允许我独自外出的条件，因为他们说“我们会想你的”，我说“我会给你们买礼物”，他们就说“太好啦，耶”。于是，我偶然发现了一台出售糖果的可爱自动售货机，计划是给每个孩子带一包，不过我也顺便给家人买了一些，我和我丈夫狼吞虎咽地吃了起来。我不确定孩子们到底有没有分到多少，但它们实在是太美味了，所以如果你看到任何海贼糖（Hay Candy）自动售货机或者
any shops selling hay candy dig in Now in Ireland they have a large supermarket chain called Dunn's and I'd already been to a Dunn's in Northampton because randomly there was one in there, I don't know why, but that was the only Dunn's I'd ever been to in the UK and I strolled through there and I brought myself a little Tippex mouse and some pens because they were things I needed for the business but also I was a little bit peckish so I did pick up some chocolate and all my days it was completely delicious so yeah apparently Dunn's chocolate is is is really worth really worth um indulging in so yeah if you're in Ireland get yourself into Dunn's and buy some mini Dunn's chocolate bars because they were utterly delicious and just at the end
任何出售海贼糖的商店，千万别错过。在爱尔兰，他们有一家大型连锁超市叫邓恩（Dunn's），我之前在北安普敦就已经去过一家邓恩了，因为那里面无缘无故地开了一家，我也不知道为什么，但那是我在英国去过的唯一一家邓恩。我在里面闲逛，给自己买了一只小修正带和一些笔，因为这些是我工作需要的东西，而且我也觉得有点饿了，所以顺便拿了一些巧克力。天哪，简直是美味绝伦。所以，爱尔兰的邓恩巧克力真的非常、非常值得一尝。如果你在爱尔兰，一定要去邓恩买一些迷你邓恩巧克力棒，因为它们简直太好吃了。就在这次导览的
of the tour Neil and I were chatting about just about lockdown what it'd been like and that my family and I had really got into ice cream during the lockdown as a way of just having family time and a little bit of a family tradition and he said oh if you like ice cream you've got to go to this one place where they sell brown bread ice cream and I was like that does not sound good brown bread ice cream and he said trust me trust me get yourself over there um and try it out so it's called Murphy's so I did exactly that I used my phone to guide myself there um and the lady there said I could film as well and then I sat and ate my delicious ice cream and I think I had two scoops I had brown bread and I
尾声，尼尔和我聊起了封锁期间的情况，以及我和家人在封锁期间是如何迷上冰淇淋的，以此作为享受家庭时间和一种家庭传统的方式。他说：“哦，如果你喜欢冰淇淋，你一定要去一个地方，他们卖黑面包冰淇淋。”当时我觉得：“这听起来一点也不好吃，黑面包冰淇淋。”但他对我说：“相信我，相信我，去那儿尝尝吧。”那家店叫墨菲（Murphy's）。于是我照做了，用手机导航找到了那里。那里的女士说我也可以进行拍摄，然后我坐在那里吃着美味的冰淇淋。我想我当时要了两个球，一个是黑面包味的，另一个我想是
think I had a peanutty one as well and they were both completely delicious in fact I might go as far as to say it was the most delicious ice cream I've eaten it was scrumdiddlyumptious as they say and I just sort of sat there on a little little seat in there and chatted to some of the staff and they said it had been so hot in the few days before that because they have so much air con but they have the door open to encourage trade and they're always out with little trays of kind of tasters for people that the condensation had just been dripping off the ceiling because it was so warm so they were delighted that it was cooler um and it was yeah if you are in Ireland I would say absolutely check
花生味的，两个都极其美味。事实上，我甚至可以说这是我吃过最美味的冰淇淋，正如他们所说，简直棒极了。我当时就坐在里面的一个小座位上，和一些员工聊了天。他们说前几天天气太热了，因为店里冷气开得很足，但为了招揽顾客，他们把门开着，而且总是拿着一小盘试吃样品给路人品尝，以至于天花板上的水汽都在往下滴，因为天气太暖和了。所以对于天气变凉，他们感到非常高兴。如果你在爱尔兰，我绝对推荐你去
out not only um Neil's walking tour I wish I don't get paid to say you that it was just it was just lovely um also check out Murphy's and then it was time to start my journey in reverse walking back through Galway towards my B&B um and yeah just enjoying the late afternoon sunshine um and I went past the pub and I was right on time um and then I noticed on the pub sign that the sign had been changed there was no session that day so that was a little bit disappointing but I did then go and have a drink out in the sunshine watching the world go by from a bar that I'd seen the day before so not quite the same as a traditional Irish session but still enjoyable nonetheless then I went back to my Airbnb I got
看看，不仅是尼尔的徒步导览——申明一下，我可没拿钱帮他说好话，纯粹是因为真的很棒——还要去看看墨菲冰淇淋。随后，我便开始原路返回，穿过高尔韦步行回到我的民宿，享受着傍晚的阳光。我路过一家酒吧，时间刚刚好，然后我注意到酒吧的招牌换了，那天没有传统音乐演奏会（session），这有点令人失望。不过，我还是去了一家前一天看到过的酒吧，坐在阳光下喝着饮料，看着人来人往，虽然算不上传统的爱尔兰音乐会，但依然十分惬意。接着我回到了爱彼迎（Airbnb）民宿，换上了
changed into something snuggly and had a cup of tea with my Airbnb host and then she'd said she would love to make me dinner which was just so kind and so that is what she did and we ate together and it was just the loveliest evening so tasty so friendly and so welcoming and then of course her lovely cat Tommy was equally as welcoming let me just spend a little bit of time with Tommy now too. You're a lovely cat. Yes, lovely. He's very happy with you. We're very happy with you, Tommy. Oh, he loves that.
一套舒适的衣服，和民宿房东一起喝了杯茶。她说她很乐意为我做晚饭，真是太善良了，于是她真的做了。我们一起用餐，度过了一个无比美好的夜晚——饭菜如此美味，气氛如此友好热情。当然，她那可爱的猫咪汤姆（Tommy）也同样热情，现在就让我花一点时间陪陪汤姆吧。你是一只可爱的猫咪。是的，很可爱。他对你很满意。我们对你也很满意，汤姆。哦，他可喜欢这样了。
Oh, he's so cute. You're the loveliest thing, aren't you? Yes, you are. Yes, you're beautiful loveliest thing aren't you yes you are yes you're beautiful you're beautiful I'm just having a cup of tea with the lovely Frances before bed because I've got an early start tomorrow and she's insistent that I must have some cake so I'm gonna have some cake and then go to bed. So I've had my cake and I've eaten it and Francis has been telling me all about people who've stayed here before and apparently in this very bed Colin Farrell stayed. He was making a film in the Isle of Arran. I've not watched the film
哦，他太可爱了。你是最可爱的宝贝，对吧？是的，你是。是的，你长得真标致，最可爱的宝贝，对吧？是的，你是。是的，你好漂亮，你好漂亮。我在睡觉前和可爱的弗朗西丝（Frances）一起喝杯茶，因为我明天一早有安排，她坚决要求我吃点蛋糕，所以我打算吃块蛋糕就去睡觉。好了，我的蛋糕已经吃过了，弗朗西丝一直在跟我讲以前住在这里的人。据说，连科林·法瑞尔（Colin Farrell）都曾住过这张床。他当时在阿兰群岛拍电影，我没看过那部电影，
but he stayed here for a few weeks and took care of Tommy the cat good fact and on that note with the time at 9 p.m I am going to go to bed um it's been what feels like quite a long day it's been lots and lots of activity. See how many steps there's been. 15,500 steps. It's been a great day in Galway. And I've got to get up really early. So I think I'm getting up at half past four. So yeah, I will love you and leave you.
但他在这里住了几个星期，还照顾了猫咪汤姆，真是一个有趣的冷知识。伴随着晚上9点的时间，我要去睡觉了。感觉今天是非常漫长的一天，有非常非常多的活动。来看看今天走了多少步吧。15500步。在高尔韦真是美好的一天。而且我得起个大早，我想我得四点半起床。所以，我要向大家道别了。
See you soon. So you can see as the video progresses that I get gradually tireder and tireder and tireder and then getting up super early the morning I flew home didn't help but I'd also had a bit of a restless night the night before because it was still quite warm and I was worried about missing my flight and so I woke up at one in the morning and then was awake for a few hours and the night before that my first night in Galway I just sort of kept thinking about the next day and about processing everything I'd experienced that day and so I just didn't sleep terrifically well then either and so I just felt like more and more depleted the time that went on so let's touch base with me now as I am up very
回头见。大家可以通过视频看出，随着时间的推移，我变得越来越疲惫。而且我飞回家那天早上起得极早，这并没有什么帮助，但前一天晚上我也没睡好，因为天气还是挺暖和的，而且我担心错过航班，所以我凌晨一点就醒了，然后醒了好几个小时。再前一天晚上，也就是我在高尔韦的第一晚，我脑子里一直在想第二天的事，一直在消化我那天经历的一切，所以那一晚我也没睡得特别好。因此，随着时间的推移，我感觉自己越来越筋疲力尽。现在让我们来看看我起得很早的状态。
early morning it is kind of early it's just gone 4 45 in the morning I am all packed up I'm ready to go I'm in the car I've had to wake up my lovely host Frances because she told me she'd be very cross if I didn't which didn't feel very nice but yeah I'm hoping I can find my way back to Shannon Airport which is a different airport than I flew out of because it wasn't possible to fly into Knock and out of Knock or into Shannon and out of Shannon at times that were human and even though this doesn't feel like human it is much better than the other options that I had looked at so I will see you hopefully when I've got some fuel a bit worried about finding fuel that might be open at this time um and how I open the fuel filler cap but I've had
大清早，时间还挺早，刚过早上4点45分。我已经收拾好行李，准备出发了。我已经在车上了，我不得不叫醒我可爱的房东弗朗西丝，因为她告诉过我，如果我没叫醒她，她会非常生气的，虽然这感觉不太好。不过，希望我能顺利找到去香农机场（Shannon Airport）的路。这不是我飞来时那个机场，因为要找到时间合适、能从诺克机场（Knock）进出或者从香农机场进出且符合人类作息的航班是不可能的。尽管这感觉并不符合人类作息，但它比我查看过的其他选项要好得多。希望等我加满油后再跟大家见面。有点担心能不能找到这个时候还开门的加油站，以及我该如何打开油箱盖，不过我在YouTube上
a little bit of a youtube research I think I know um and yeah hopefully I can get to the airport get a hire car back get myself sorted pass all the Ryanair checks and be away. So as I was driving, it was so foggy in patches. So I had to go nice and slowly and steady. And I did pass a few petrol stations, but they weren't that close to the airport. So I sort of ignored those because I thought I don't want to fill up the tank and then have it not be on full when I get back there. And I assumed to be one pretty close to the junction for the airport, but there was not. And so I found myself on the site of the airport still not having filled up.
做了一点研究，我想我知道怎么弄了。希望我能顺利到达机场，还掉租车，安顿好自己，通过瑞安航空（Ryanair）的所有安检，然后顺利启程。我开车的时候，一路上断断续续地遇到好大的雾，所以我只能平稳地慢速行驶。我的确路过了几个加油站，但它们离机场不够近，所以我把它们忽略了，因为我想我可不想加满油，结果到还车时油箱却不是满的。我以为机场路口附近会有一个加油站，但并没有。结果我发现自己已经到了机场范围内，却还没加满油。
So I then had to turn around and go back into Shannon Town and then use my trusty sat nav to look for the closest petrol station that was open. So yeah, I did manage to do that, but it made it a little bit more fraught than it probably needed to be. So the people near Shannon airport, you may want to open a petrol station on the motorway near Shannon Airport because many people will be hiring cars that need to be returned on full so you're missing a trick so in the end I think I ended up shopping at the Circle K in Shannon so thank you very much to you good people for being open at 5 30 in the morning on a Sunday morning or whatever time it was it was very early by the time I got there but get there I did I'm looking a little disheveled as I was in the airport so I am all checked in at Shannon Airport which is a lovely airport I have to say and you can carry your own
因此，我不得不掉头回香农镇，然后用我可靠的卫星导航寻找最近开门的加油站。好吧，我确实成功找到了，但这比原本需要的要让人紧张一些。所以住在香农机场附近的朋友们，你们或许可以考虑在香农机场附近的公路上开一家加油站，因为很多人都会租用需要加满油归还的汽车，你们这是在错过商机啊。最后，我想我是在香农的Circle K加油站搞定的。非常感谢你们这些好心人，在周日清晨或者不知道到底几点的凌晨5点30分还在营业。我到那里时时间已经非常早了，但我确实到了。我在机场里看起来有点衣衫不整。我已经完成了香农机场的登机手续，不得不说这是一个很可爱的机场，而且你可以自己把
water and drinks through with no problems which is good now I'm just gonna wait for my flight the lovely Frances packed me off with breakfast this morning she made it for me last night popped it in the fridge uh so i've had strawberries and raspberries and a bottle of water which is just so lovely so i was there i got checked in had my breakfast um and then it was just you know time to wait so the flight coming back was similarly as effortless as the one going out but it was quieter which meant that I had three whole seats to myself which is always a bit of a treat but it was so short haul that there wasn't any time for kind of laying flat and napping which was something I had enjoyed when I was traveling around the world in 2003.
水和饮料带过安检，没有任何问题，这挺好的。现在我只需要等我的航班。今天早上，可爱的弗朗西丝为我准备了早餐，她昨晚做好了放进冰箱里的。所以我有草莓、覆盆子和一瓶水，真是太贴心了。我在那儿办好登机手续，吃完早餐，然后就是等待的时间了。回程的航班和去程一样轻松，但人更少，这意味着我一个人占了整整三个座位，这总归是一种享受。不过航程太短了，根本没有时间躺平打个盹，这倒是我2003年环游世界时挺享受的一种体验。
My friend and I had both managed on a long haul flight to get I think it was like a row of four or five seats to ourselves so essentially had a flatbed experience for backpacker prices which was just wonderful. Yeah it wasn't quite a flatbed experience on Ryanair but it was very speedy and actually I have to say that um even when I was flying back into Birmingham the baggage carousel situation was amazing for both flights my baggage was pretty much there as soon as I'd been and had a trip to the ladies and then I was at the carousel and it was there whereas in contrast when I was flying back from Birmingham in the summer we'd had to wait about an hour for all of our bags to appear so I was kind of
我和朋友在长途飞行中都设法占了我想是四五排座位中的一整排，所以基本上享受到了背包客价格的平躺体验，简直太棒了。好吧，在瑞安航空上虽然算不上平躺体验，但速度非常快。而且事实上，我必须说，甚至当我飞回伯明翰时，两个航班的行李转盘情况都太棒了。我刚去完洗手间回到转盘处，我的行李基本上就已经在那儿了。相比之下，今年夏天我从伯明翰飞回来时，我们不得不等大约一个小时才看到所有行李出现，所以我当时其实
anticipating that was going to be the case it was a very pleasant surprise so very well done to the luggage crew at both Knock and Birmingham airports. I am now back in the drop off zone at Birmingham airport and I'm waiting for my Uber. Shouldn't be too long. I am really quite tired now and feel quite dishevelled. And I'm looking forward to getting home. Thank you so much for following my journey from door to door. I'll do a quick one when i get home and then that will be all hope you found it useful i hope you found it inspiring and helpful for kind of thinking about when you have new things to do that might feel challenging that might feel a bit overwhelming you've got this thank you very much and I'll look forward to catching up with you again soon so tired just
预料到这次也会那样，结果却是一个非常惊喜的意外。所以，诺克机场和伯明翰机场的行李搬运团队干得好。我现在已经回到伯明翰机场的下客区，正在等我的优步（Uber）。应该很快就到。我现在真的非常累，感觉也挺狼狈的，很期待能快点到家。非常感谢大家一路跟随我的门到门行程。我到家后会快速录一个视频，然后就结束啦。希望你觉得这有价值，希望它能给你带来启发和帮助，让你在面对可能具有挑战性、可能感觉有点压力的全新事物时，能够告诉自己：“我能行！”非常感谢大家，期待很快与大家再叙。实在太累了，刚刚
back from Marianne Galway is going to be closing this episode but I did think that I would just say a few thank yous so thank you very much to the Irish Psychological Society for inviting me to be their keynote speaker. It was lovely. I loved it. And I had so many interesting, inspiring chats with people both at the event and since you've contacted me on social. So yeah, thank you for curating a really wonderful, supportive, friendly group of people and wishing you very well and wishing you all the best in what you do next and how you support the future generations of psychologists too also want to thank um my airbnb host and her son for being so welcoming sorting everything out for me and of course tommy the cat um and i want to thank you guys for listening um and yeah if anyone listening is interested in booking me for keynote um speeches in future or would like me to come and do some sort of behind the scenes vlog of a conference
从高尔韦的玛丽安那儿回来，这集播客就要接近尾声了，但我还是想表达一些感谢。非常感谢爱尔兰心理学协会（Irish Psychological Society）邀请我担任他们的大会主旨发言人。太美妙了，我很喜欢。在活动期间以及后来通过社交媒体联系我的人中，我和许多有趣、鼓舞人心的人进行了交流。所以，谢谢你们打造了一个非常棒、充满支持且友好的群体，祝你们一切顺利，在未来的工作中以及支持心理学未来一代方面取得巨大成功。我还要感谢我的爱彼迎房东和她的儿子如此热情地接待我，为我安排好了一切，当然还有猫咪汤姆。我还想感谢收听节目的各位。如果有听众对未来邀请我做主旨
or an event let me know and we'll see what we can do. I've had fun with this. I'd also like to thank my podcast editor who kind of inspired this little vlog thing because he asked me whether I ever take any b-roll footage of actually what I'm up to in the day and I was like no, I don't. It's not very exciting. So this time I thought, well, this is more exciting. It's been a labour of love, this podcast video has taken me ages. So I thought, well, this is much more exciting than what I usually get up to. And it's nice to have company when you're on tour. So I thought I'd bring you with me. So yeah, hope that you've put up with my
演讲感兴趣，或者希望我来为某个会议或活动拍摄一些幕后花絮视频，请告诉我，我们看看能怎么安排。这次拍摄很有意思。我还要感谢我的播客剪辑师，是他激发了制作这个小视频的想法，因为他问过我，在日常生活中我有没有拍摄过任何关于自己实际在做什么的B卷素材。而我的回答是：“没有，我没有。那没什么意思。”所以这次我想，这其实更有意思。这是一项充满热情的劳动，制作这个播客视频花了我好长时间。我想，这比我平时做的事有意思多了。而且在巡回活动时有人做伴也挺好的，所以我想把你们也带上。希望你们能忍受我的
camera work that you can cope with me getting tired and tired as things progress I am now filming this a good few weeks after the event I've recovered my tiredness but it is now at the end of a working week I've had a busy day and I'm back from swimming with the kids I've just finished dinner so even getting the a-roll snippets ready for this video have just taken me a little while so you may notice I've changed outfits a few times but I really wanted to bring this to you so let's let Marianne who's now back in her house fresh from Galway just utterly shattered let's let her sign off but thank you very much for watching that is it I am home and I had such an interesting chat with my uber driver on the way home about all things football and then the fact that he'd actually been a law graduate originally and then got a 2-2 and we kind of worked out together actually he's a bit traumatized by that and we kind of encouraged him
摄像技术，能够忍受随着时间的推移我越来越疲惫的状态。我现在录制这段视频时，距离活动已经过去了整整几个星期。我的疲惫已经恢复了，但现在正值一个工作周的尾声，我忙碌了一整天，刚和孩子们游完泳回来，也刚吃完晚饭。所以仅仅是把这段视频的A卷素材准备好就花了我不少时间。你们可能会发现我换了好几次衣服，但我真的很想把这个视频呈现给大家。好了，就让已经回到家中、刚从高尔韦回来、累得精疲力竭的玛丽安来做个结语吧。非常感谢大家的观看，就这样，我到家了。在回家的路上，我和优步司机进行了一次非常有趣的聊天，聊的都是足球相关的事情。然后聊到他其实原本是个法律专业毕业生，后来拿了个二等二级学位（2-2），我们一起探讨了一下，觉得他其实对此有点心理阴影。我们鼓励他
to move through that and to think about the steps involved with perhaps studying for a master's and then beginning to get back into the law career so by the time I got out the uber he'd come up with a bit we'd come up with a bit of a plan how many steps he's going to spend a few minutes before his next job um looking at maybe some masters and you know maybe thinking about sending some emails off to get that started so yeah love love my job love the chats that I end up having with people and he's like thank you so much Marianne this has been really really good like and it's kind of empowering stuff that potentially begins to change his life and the life of his family as well although he sounds like he's doing a great job anyway but you know sometimes when we feel
走出来，思考一下接下来攻读硕士学位并重新开始法律职业生涯所需要经历的步骤。所以等我下车时，我们已经一起想出了一个初步计划。他将在接下来的第一单生意开始前的几分钟里，抽空看看一些硕士课程，或许考虑发几封电子邮件来把这事儿起个头。我太热爱我的工作了，也热爱我跟人们进行的各种交流。他说：“非常感谢你，玛丽安，这真的太好了。”这是一种能够赋予人力量的东西，它有可能开始改变他的人生，以及他家人的生活——尽管听起来他现在的工作也干得很棒，但你知道的，有时当我们觉得
like we need to and want to live up to our full potential and the things that you're originally you know heading in that direction for so it matters it really matters um and we're never too never too old to do what we want to do so i think he said he's 30 34 i think he said and i was was like, you know, time is young. You know, just do what you want to do. Yeah. So thank you very much for following my journey. My children and my husband are out.
需要并且想要发挥出自己的全部潜能时，去追求那些你最初朝着那个方向努力的目标，这很重要，真的非常重要。而且我们永远不会太老，不会老到无法去做自己想做的事。我想他说他30岁，34岁吧，当时我对他说：“你知道的，你还年轻得很。去做你想做的事吧。”所以，非常感谢大家一路跟随我的旅程。我的孩子们和丈夫都出去了，
I think one of them might be at the grandparents and the other one's at football. So I'm going to enjoy a little bit of peace and quiet. I wish I could have a nap. I'm quite tired. But yeah, I will see you for the next episode of the podcast which will be coming to you from 6am on Monday thank you so much for being part of my world if you're watching on YouTube please do subscribe like let me know what you found useful about this episode and I'll look forward to seeing you very soon. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified
我想其中一个可能在祖父母家，另一个在踢足球。所以我要享受一会儿难得的宁静。我真希望能小睡一会儿，我实在太累了。不过，我会和大家在下期播客中见，节目将于周一早上6点准时上线。非常感谢大家成为我世界的一部分。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅、点赞，并让我知道这集节目对你有用，我非常期待很快与大家见面。保重。让这成为你的向导，有这档播客陪伴在侧，你将踏上获得专业资质的道路。
it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist
这里是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安博士。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书，觉得里面关于各种不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有多少不同的途径可以通往这个职业，这让我感到惊讶，而且并没有成为其中一员的唯一完美途径。这让我充满了信心，让我觉得自己并没有做错，也减轻了内心的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，
I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，就根本停不下来。这一集暂时还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。